dr. Brown you've talked about
non-monetary hoarders that could include
sanctions like orders to undertake
sensitivity and anti bias training I
would like either one or both of you to
comment on whether you could explain why
an individual may have a strong
objection to undertaking such a training
and mr. Brown could you let the
committee know how serious the sanction
could be and of course you already did
on that if you refuse to undertake such
an order and specifically at the federal
level but what would what would why
would people have an objection to taking
such training I think I mean like dr.
Peterson answer why he or someone like
him might have an objection to
undertaking I pay for training and then
I'll deal obviously but once again with
the severity of that decision if it gets
before the tribunal well I have a
profound objection to to undergoing such
training in fact I would flatly refuse
under all conditions to undergo it and
the reason there's multiple reasons for
that the first reason is that the
science surrounding the the so-called
charge of implicit bias that's
associated with perception is by no
means settled in in to such a degree
that to one of the three people who
designed the most commonly used measure
which is the implicit association test
has detached himself from the other two
researchers on the grounds that the use
of the test has become as far
transcended its scientific validity and
reliability it's nowhere near valid or
reliable enough to be used in the manner
that it's been using and even the more
Pro IAT researchers to develop the test
have admitted to that publicly even
though they haven't stressed it nearly
to the degree they showed it so first of
all the sciences is not settled and is
being used
absolutely inappropriately and I can say
that as a clinician because I know the
Quran is a psychometrician I know the
criteria for using a test for sex
essentially diagnostic purposes and the
IAT doesn't even come close to what's
necessary then the next issue is well
where is the evidence that that anti
unconscious bias training works there's
no evidence and what little evidence
there is suggests that it actually has
the opposite effect because people don't
like being brought in front of a
reeducation committee and having their
fundamental
exceptions you see their perceptions not
even their thoughts but their
perceptions themselves altered by
collective siat it's an unbelievable
error sir we have a very engaged
Committee concise questions and concise
responses with the helpful law senator
Pratt